[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le bangladesh
comment se tiennent pays le plus pauvre
épidémie de choléra le défi terry de
tuberculose à votre avis qu'est-ce qui
tue le plus aujourd'hui au bangladesh
les épidémies la malnutrition
la violence est maintenant ce qui tue de
plus aujourd'hui au bangladesh
c'est le vieillissement et plus
particulièrement toutes les maladies qui
en découlent comme une bonne partie des
cancers et des infarctus
alors je vous pose pas la question pour
la suisse c'est pareil sur presque toute
la planète chaque seconde de personnes
meurent d'une maladie liée au
vieillissement la manière la plus simple
de voir le vieillissement c'est de le
voir comme un programme génétique
d'autodestruction présent chacun d'entre
vous dont on commence à voir les effets
vers 20 ans et qui double vos chances de
mourir dans l'année tous les sept ans je
sais c'est pas fun oui mais c'est comme
ça la bonne nouvelle c'est que lorsque
vous avez 20 ans et que le
vieillissement n'a pas encore d'effets
soit mortalité vous avez une chance sur
mille de mourir dans l'année ce qui veut
dire qu'en l'absence de vieillissement
l'espérance de vie moyenne en bonne
santé d'un français moyen serait de
milan
et du coup la deuxième question se pose
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire contre ça et
bien c'est ça quatre étapes 1
identifier les causes fondamentales du
vieillissement 2 essayer de les traiter
3 mesurer le résultat de ces traitements
4 recommencer et si possible faire le
plus vite possible c'est-à-dire ne pas
attendre soixante dix ans entre deux
mesures donc facile identifié traité
mesure et recommencer encore et encore
un poisson rouge pour y arriver alors ça
a l'air simple et vous allez voir on
n'est pas aidés et pourtant il ya du
budget ce que vous imaginez bien qu'on
se donne les moyens au niveau mondial
d'arrêter un truc qui tue deux personnes
par seconde en l'occurrence 200
milliards d'euros par an 200 milliards
d'euros par 25 euros par an et par
personne
ça c'est du budget investi par les
entreprises de télécommunications chaque
année pour passer la 4g à la 5g pourra
voir des vidéos plus précis sur votre
smartphone le budget gouvernemental au
niveau mondial pour lutter contre le
vieillissement
ces 200 millions d'euros par an mille
fois moins que pour passer de la kadji à
la 5g l'avait dit on lui par ibm mais
ceci dit même malgré ses budgets la
lutte contre le vieillissement avance
plus vite que jamais beaucoup plus vite
en fait principalement parce que la
révolution en cours dans domaine des
biotechnologies nous donne pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité de sérieux espoir d'arriver à
ralentir et par même stop et le
vieillissement humains d'ici la fin du
siècle et en particulier trois
technologies
j'ai longtemps parlé dans un autre est
le pas m'appesantir ici pourrait nous
permettre de ralentir fortement
vieillissement dans les deux décédés à
bien la première à ces technologies
c'est le big data génétique il a donné
la possibilité de séquencer c'est-à-dire
de lire le génome de millions
d'individus et qui nous permettra avec
une intelligence artificielle adéquat de
faire le lien entre chaque gène chaque
maladie et l'espérance de vie de chaque
personne
la deuxième technologie c'est les
thérapies géniques un domaine qui avance
très vite ces vingt dernières années et
qui nous permet d'éditer de plus en plus
finement le génome d'une personne célia
de le modifier
et 3d avancée phénoménale dans le
domaine et c'est le souche
par exemple aujourd'hui on peut prendre
les cellules de peau d'une personne et
reproduire les cellules de base de
n'importe lequel de ses organes
alors ça va être pratique pour réparer
des organes défaillants par exemple mais
surtout ça va nous permettre de tester
tous les traitements expérimentaux
compte le vieillissement non pas comme
avant sur des animaux des êtres humains
mais directement sur une version
miniature de vos organes alors vous
allez me dire avoir des outils pour
développer des nouveaux traitements
c'est bien mais être capable de mesurer
pour voir si c'est traitement fonctionne
c'est quand même beaucoup mieux et en
l'occurrence nous manquons terriblement
de données médicales
on ne fait même pas quoi mesurer pour
identifier rapidement et précisément si
un traitement complet glissement
fonctionner j'ai de dire pourquoi
et bien tout simplement pour une raison
administrative
le vieillissement n'est pas considérée
comme une maladie et donc on n'a pas le
droit de faire de tests cliniques dessus
et pas de tests cliniques pas de données
médicales de qualité et pas de
traitement homologué non plus d'ailleurs
edit mais pas l'aider et pourtant c'est
important d'être capable de mesurer
c'est un traitement qu'on peut
licitement fonctionne pour pouvoir
l'améliorer déjà et surtout pour pouvoir
l'homologuer parce qu'avant c'est en
aveugle ça n'est pas très loin
je sais pas si vous avez déjà essayé un
jour de faire le tour du monde à pied
eh ben c'est pas facile mais essayer de
le faire les yeux rien nous aidant on a
à peu près dans cette situation
concernant la lutte contre le
vieillissement humain enfin presque
on a quoi comme donné sous la main
on a quelques études longitudinales
c'est à dire mener sur des dizaines
d'années à vocation de médecine générale
comme l'étude d'une eddine où des
chercheurs ont mesuré le plus
précisément possible l'état de santé de
plusieurs milliers de personnes qui
vivaient dans la petite ville de dunedin
il n'en fut pendant des dizaines
d'années alors ça ça nous aurait appris
énormément
par exemple vous servir qu'après 30 ans
et bavent un petit peu d'embonpoint la
petite vous aideront pas ça porte
malheur en termes d'espérance 2 alors
vraiment malheur et ceci dit même si on
a beaucoup appris là maintenant on a
fait le tour et leur lancer une étude
longitudinale bien malheureusement que
ça prend des dizaines d'années on a
également quelques publications
scientifiques qui nous ont montré qu'il
existait des ensembles de biomarqueurs
qui semblait varier avec le
vieillissement chez les animaux et
depuis une petite dizaine d'années chez
les êtres humains alors des biomarqueurs
c'est tout ce qu'on peut mesurer dans un
organisme par un peu votre taille le
poids le cholestérol la glycémie sont
tous des biomarqueurs alors été très
content découvrir tout ça par contre on
s'est aperçu que pris indépendamment
tous ces biomarqueurs soit morphologie
génétique et 10 génétique ne nous donne
pas trop le même âge ça c'est pas
pratique et en plus ils avancent pas à
la même vitesse
j'ai la même personne
le rentrant dans le détail qu'est ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui comme méthode
lorsqu'on veut mesurer son propre
vieillissement
on a ce qu'on appelle la méthode
morphologiques alors vous les connaissez
tous
si on se regarde dans un miroir comme ça
quand on regarde nos rides qui est un
très bon indicateur du vieillissement de
notre peau aussi non pour garder nos
cheveux blancs par exemple qui est un
très bon indicateur également du
vieillissement des cellules souches du
follicule pileux
ça paraît bancal et ça allait souvent
donc si vous avez beaucoup d'argent que
vous pouvez aussi aller dans une
clinique spécialisée où on viendra à
mesurer le vieillissement de la fonction
de chacun de vos organes au saut modo
par exemple on va vous dire fermez les
yeux tenez vous sur un pied on appelle
un pesto de peau d'âne et ça ça va
mesurer des glissements de vos fonctions
neuromotrice on va faire mesurer la
régie pub aux artères faire une vo2 max
gérez votre glycémie pour un regardez
dans quel état et votre pancréas oui
l'idée
et enfin si vous avez accès un
laboratoire particulièrement pointue
dans le domaine de la lutte contre le
vieillissement
alors là vous aurez accès à des méthodes
de mesures beaucoup plus proche des
causes fondamentales du vieillissement
humain alors sa part et barbare mais
vous pourrez mesurer la vitesse de votre
horloge d'horvath pour mesurer votre
vieillissement et des génétique
vous mesurez l'attrition de voter
l'omert les cellules d'intérêt je pas
rentrer dans le détail
en tous les cas ça reste assez célèbre
vous le cache pas disons que vous avez à
peu près autant de chances d'avoir accès
à ce type de métrologie que dans
laboratoire en bas de chez vous que
d'être invité une crémaillère sur la
station spatiale internationale
croyez moi dans tous les cas vous en
faites pas parce que comme je vous
disais auparavant
tous ces ensembles de biomarqueurs pris
séparément soit morphologiques
épigénétiques tout ce qu'on veut ne nous
donne pas le même âge n'avance pas à la
même vitesse
et pourquoi et bien parce que nous
vieillissons de plusieurs manières
différentes
depuis une petite trentaine d'années la
communauté scientifique ça pas bouger
puis a identifié neuf causes
fondamentales du vieillissement chez
l'être humain et chacune d'entre elles a
sa propre horloge qui avance à sa propre
vitesse et c'est pour ça que toutes nos
méthodes de mesure du vieillissement
global même âge parce qu'elles sont
probablement aurele à une ou plusieurs
poses différentes jaillissement
or je disais ce qui serait bien pour
faire avancer la recherche de nouveaux
traitements qu'on peut vieillissement
c'est d'être capable de mesurer assez
précisément des quasiment en temps réel
le vieillissement de quelqu'un et pour
réussir à faire ça le plus sain c'est
d'identifier mesurer tous les
biomarqueurs au niveau moléculaire et
cellulaire directement liés à chacune
des neuf cause du vieillissement et
c'est important de mesurer les choses au
niveau cellulaire et non pas au niveau
de l'organe comme on le fait aujourd'hui
si on prend la maladie d'alzheimer les
premiers symptômes au niveau du cerveau
en termes de dépenses apparaissent des
années après des problèmes
les premiers problèmes sévères
et du coup pour identifier ces ensembles
de biomarqueurs liés aux neuf cause du
vieillissement
on a besoin de quoi eh bien on a besoin
juste d'une seule chose
deux montagnes de données médicales à
l'échelle de populations entières pour
pouvoir faire des corrélations entre
l'âge des gens leur état de santé et
tous les deux marqueurs qu'on arrive à
mesurer chez eux en mesurer des
palanquées la bonne nouvelle des bonnes
nouvelles aujourd'hui on fait un à plein
temps d'en parler
la bonne nouvelle c'est que certaines
entreprises comme google ou certains
pays comme l'estonie paix dit très en
avance ont lancé des initiatives pour
collecter et organiser les données
médicales à l'échelle de populations
entières alors malheureusement pour nous
c'est démarche plutôt des vocations de
médecine générale et pas spécifiquement
liés au vieillissement mais ça va
vraiment dans le bon sens c'est la
première fois que ça arrive dans
l'histoire de l'humanité il ceci dit
même à aix et donné je vais être
transparent avec vous ça va rester coton
d'arrêter ou voir même de ralentir
fortement vieillissement humain dans les
décennies à venir et on oublie souvent
au cours du 20e siècle
lorsqu'on avait réellement une volonté
politique de faire les choses
certaines choses qui paraissent est
presque impossible à leur époque ont été
réalisées en moins d'une décennie
je vous donner l'exemple par exemple de
kennedy il s'est écoulé moins sept ans
entre le moment où john fitzgerald
kennedy a déclaré qu'ils voulaient
envoyer un américain sur la lune est le
premier pas de neil armstrong l'un
identiquement il s'est écoulé moins de
six ans entre les premières recherches
sur la bombe atomique et le premier
essai nucléaire
on remarquera au passage comme
d'habitude ce concept pour ce truc sur
la gueule ya du monde on pense qu'ils
jouent conserve c'est un peu plus
compliqué mais bon revenons à nos
moutons
quand je vous disais
toutes ces démarches de collecte de
données fait par google est né et bien
d'autres acteurs n'ont pas vocation à
accélérer les recherches en ce
vieillissement et du coup plutôt que
rester les bras croisés comme ça avec
mes collègues
en parallèle deux autres cherchent on a
décidé de lancer une initiative de
collecte de données médicales
spécifiquement pour accélérer la
recherche quant au vieillissement
alors qu'est ce qu'on a fait eh ben on
propose une application gratuite qui
mesurent l'espérance de vie des gens ils
estiment plus exactement les gens auront
choix de rentrer par ampleur dans et
morphologiques génétique épigénétiques
biochimiques tous les traitements qui
prennent en compte le vieillissement
s'ils seront prêts et on retour ils
auront une estimation plus ou moins
précises sont excusés ans rentrés de
leur espérance de vie et surtout dans
leur cas précis comment l'améliorer
alors pourquoi les gens fressin même
principalement parce que mesurée
connaître son espérance de vie et savoir
ce qu'ils dérapent mais ça permet de le
corriger ça permet justement d'augmenter
son espérance de vie en bonne santé et à
nous en tant que chercheur ça va nous
servir à quoi
voilà comme ça va à part avoir le
plaisir d'augmenter l'espérance de vie
nos utilisateurs ce qui est déjà un
grand plaisir
ça va nous servir à rien par contre y
aurait une petite case que les gens
pourront cocher et qui nous autorisera à
utiliser de manière anonyme
toutes les données médicales qui
rentrent dans l'application pour
accélérer la recherche pour tous les dix
mètres
vous allez dire mais qu'est ce qu'on va
faire de ça et bien comme des aimants
collègue christophe paniquer ça va nous
permettre de construire un décor
clinique homogène après cette période de
pic de bonheur comme ça je vous raconte
pas ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire quoi reconstituer des corps
de gens ayant des caractéristiques
similaires et un seul détail qui change
par exemple 1000 personnes de 50 ans
certains prenons du resvératrol une
molécule assez connus comme supplément
contre le vieillissement et d'autres non
ça va nous permettre de voir
éventuellement qu'effectivement à 50 ans
c'est une très bonne idée de prendre 500
mg de resvératrol par jour mais que par
contre lorsqu'on à telle ou telle
mutation génétique ça devient une très
mauvaise idée
donc ça nous permettra d'une part donner
les meilleurs conseils aux gens et les
applications
c'est déjà ça mais surtout ça va nous
permettre d'envoyer tous nos résultats
d'études à tous les laboratoires de
recherche qui travaille pour élaborer
des nouveaux traitements de
vieillissement et du coup cette fois ci
pour le fait en connaissance de cause
le problème c'est qu'on n'hésite pas à
sortir tout de suite parce qu'avec ces
choses là on évite hors-la-loi et ça va
pas vraiment faire avancer ma cause si
je passe vingt ans en prison
donc on a mis nos avocats dessus travail
c'est très bien en parallèle on améliore
nos algo vous le dira jamais de mal
c'est presque sans fin ces améliorations
d'armes et peut-être vous allez me
demander pourquoi est ce qu'on fait ça
et bien tout simplement offert en sorte
que le but de l'ongle en live devienne
une réalité et notre but
il est simple c'est donner le choix john
est le choix le plus rapidement possible
à chaque être humain entre vieillir et
ne pas l'élire faire en sorte que chacun
puisse décider de vivre aussi longtemps
qu'ils le souhaitent en bonne santé
pourquoi on va faire ça juste parce que
ça nous paraît mille fois de plus
important que de passer de la 4g à la 5g
voilà j'ai fini ma confiance
j'espère vous avez passé un bon moment
au moins vous avez appris quelque chose
je vous laisse y réfléchir on en reparle
dans trois semaines merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]